le système solaire est organisé et
chaque planète a un rôle à jouer autour
du Soleil la matière est organisée
chaque atome a un rôle bien déterminé à
jouer à l'intérieur de la molécule
la France doit être organisée car tout
ne doit pas dépendre de Paris
la structure urbaine de la France doit
être revue car à l'heure actuelle seul 4
villes dépassent 500 000 habitants
[Musique]
pour des raisons bien souvent
historiques on en trouve 6 en Italie
et 11 en Allemagne fédérale
le problème de l'aménagement du
territoire est un problème
d'organisation chaque ville doit avoir
un rôle défini à son échelle à côté de
Paris capitale à l'échelle mondiale il
faut créer deux villes d'importance
européenne
si métropole inter régional
[Musique]
vocation régionale plus une trentaine de
centres urbains
ces villes doivent attirer et garder les
étudiants et les élèves des grandes
écoles
les sièges sociaux des grandes
entreprises
ceux qui veulent se distraire en mettant
à leur disposition les installations
culturelles et sportives indispensables
et surtout ceux qui veulent trouver un
emploi
mais il ne suffit pas de revoir la
structure urbaine de la France si l'on
ignore le problème des grands réseaux de
communication centrée autour de la
capitale un habitant d'Angers se rend à
Dijon s'il veut avoir son rendez-vous
dans l'après-midi il devra faire 100 km
de plus et passer par Paris dont il ne
connaîtra que la navette interga
cette étoile devant Notre-Dame de Paris
et le point de départ des 14 national
les plus importants il faudra donc
moderniser les communications routières
comme à Tancarville créé de grands axes
transversaux aménager les voies
navigables comme le Grand Canal d'Alsace
[Musique]
pour suivre l'électrification des voies
ferrées
[Musique]
dans les grandes villes de province des
aérodromes pour assurer des relations
rapides
améliorer les liaisons internationales
comme il a été fait au Mont Blanc alors
pour eux dans 20 ans la France aura un
tout autre visage
il est encore rare de trouver des usines
implantées en pleine nature pourtant ce
spectacle existe maintenant pourquoi
parce que des villes de province ont su
les accueillis peau est un exemple
caractéristique d'une cité en expansion
les facteurs de son développement l'AC
évidemment car cette richesse naturelle
a permis la naissance d'un complexe
industriel unique en France ce sont des
milliers d'emplois qui furent créés dans
cette zone quelque peu déshérités
[Musique]
mais lac n'explique pas l'évolution
démographique de Pau puisqu'à Mourenx
une ville a été créée pour accueillir
les employés du complexe alors quelles
sont les motifs qui ont permis à peau de
passer en moins de 10 ans de 40 à 60 000
habitants cette ville a joué
essentiellement sur deux tableaux et là
immédiatement installé un institut de
droit des collèges de lettres et de
sciences d'un des locaux provisoires
mais un vaste ensemble universitaire se
prépare
[Musique]
l'enseignement secondaire possède des
locaux pour près de 5000 lycéens
l'enseignement primaire pour plus de
8000 écoliers et un effort tout
particulier a été réalisé en faveur du
technique un lycée prépare les
techniciens et les ouvriers spécialisés
que les industriels recherchent
[Musique]
un centre d'apprentissage féminin
complète l'équipement scolaire
la ville peut également offrir de
nombreux loisirs indispensables élément
pour fixer les cadres éloignés de la
capitale
[Musique]
pour engager un deuxième pari sur la
construction et l'urbanisme la ville qui
avait la forme d'un V dont le centre
était vide a établi un plan d'urbanisme
dans lequel s'intègre la construction
des facultés et celle des logements
[Musique]
trouver un logement est un des facteurs
essentiels qui déterminent le choix
d'une localisation industrielle ce ne
sont pas des industries lourdes comme
celle de lac que la ville veut attirer
mais des industries complémentaires
petites unités d'une centaine d'emplois
chacune déjà plusieurs industriels se
sont établies dans la ville une fabrique
de chaussures une
usine de matériel magnétique d'autres
encore pour orienter cette expansion une
zone industrielle est en voie de
création sur le territoire d'une commune
voisine d'ores et déjà l'activité
commerciale et la preuve que peau a
gagné son pari l'expansion rapide de
peau et le résultat des efforts et des
initiatives d'une ville qui a misé avec
raison sur l'avenir l'expansion
industrielle en permettant la création
d'emplois est souvent le seul moyen de
sortir des villages ou des villes de
leur léthargie
ici c'est un simple atelier d'une
cinquantaine de personnes qui
s'installent dans un vieux moulin et
évite ainsi à quelques dizaines de
familles une pénible migration
[Musique]
Château-du-Loir bourgade de 5000
habitants ancien relais de bagnard la
fermeture d'un dépôt de la SNCF occupant
plusieurs centaines de personnes amena
une dégradation de l'activité économique
pour la redresser des usines furent
construites et mis en location-vente
formules originale qui a réussi et qui a
donné une réelle expansion à cette ville
où 800 emplois ont été créés mais à
l'heure de l'automation le problème de
la main d'oeuvre reste le problème clé
des yeux et des mains de qualité que une
machine usuelles ne peut pas remplacer
des yeux et des mains de qualité que
peuvent offrir des travailleurs sans
formation professionnelle
[Musique]
à Dijon c'est une localisation
industrielle à grande échelle que nous
trouvons installez dans le voisinage
immédiat des nouveaux immeubles où là où
j'ai une grande partie de la main
d'oeuvre disponible l'usine a mal à la
création d'un centre intellectuel en
liaison avec la Faculté des Sciences
centre qui forme les ingénieurs de
l'industrie électronique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
désirant limiter à 2000 le personnel de
l'usine de Dijon cette industrie
installa des annexes dans 5
agglomérations voisines comment choisir
une commune dans chaque mairie ceux qui
désiraient travailler dans l'industrie
se faisait inscrire un deuxième élément
intervenait on cherchait de la main
d'oeuvre masculine sale baume avec ses
12000 habitants pouvaient permettre de
la trouver
[Musique]
on désirait de la main d'oeuvre féminine
Genlis pouvait l'offrir ayant déjà réglé
par ailleurs le problème de l'emploi des
hommes
[Musique]
l'usine se rapproche donc de la main
mieux dans un rayon de quelques
kilomètres un quart va chercher les
ouvriers à proximité de leur domicile
cette expérience va donner un nouvel
essor à la vieille capitale
bourguignonne et à toute sa région
[Musique]
on va construire une cité à Hérouville
c'est-à-dire plusieurs quartiers autour
d'un centre avec son commerce et son
administration pour la circulation plus
de Carrefour des branches en y
les voitures ne rentrent pas dans les
quartiers réservés aux piétons mais il
faut tout voir pour comprendre
l'urbanisme alors reprenons au début et
suivant l'opération qui se prépare près
de Caen
pour répondre à des besoins immédiats
quand ville en expansion a créé tout un
secteur d'habitation mais il ne suffit
pas de loger un plan d'urbanisme lui
doit aller plus loin
l'urbanisme moderne a maintenant pour
but de créer des villes qui répondent
aux quatre fonctions logées travaillées
circulaient se cultivait mais dans ces
villes édifiées de toutes pièces il faut
permettre comme autrefois
l'épanouissement de toutes les activités
pourraient aux villes la société
d'équipements de Basse-Normandie a mis
en concours le plan d'une ville de 40
000 habitants sur ce terrain de 300
hectares elle va être construite en
fonction de différents pôles
d'attractions les usines existantes et
les zones industrielles ou plusieurs
milliers d'emplois vont être créés à
quelques minutes du lieu d'habitation
la ville de Caen et son université qui
ajoutera au potentiel intellectuel de la
ville de demain
et aussi la mer à quelques kilomètres
[Musique]
Hérouville se dressera sur ses prairies
et le projet de l'Union d'architecte et
d'urbanisme prévoit la ville avec un
centre lié à six quartiers différents un
parc est des jardins des volumes variés
cet ensemble a été modelé sur le terrain
et sa silhouette et celle d'une ville de
l'importance de Chartres
l'élément de base de la ville et le
quartier dont les 5000 habitants peuvent
se connaître le chauffeur peut être
courtois car la circulation est continue
à sens unique sans croisement ni feu
quittons la route qu'aucun immeuble ne
bordent après la passerelle qui nous
mène au quartier importer nous réserve
la surprise d'une place vous ne
connaissez pas ce genre de place car ici
tout est calme pas de voiture l'homme
est dans son milieu
l'espace se resserre pour retrouver le
coup d'accoud d'une rue marchande
laissons la foule l'horizon se dégage la
verdure resurgit pour salir à la pierre
grâce à ses nouveaux principes
d'urbanisme
Hérouville va répondre au désir de tous
ses habitants quelle que soit leur
profession leur façon de vivre leur âge
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]